Thanks again for being here
every time.
I saw that your name tag said
"Tyler from New Orleans."
-New Orleans, yeah, born and
raised, New Orleans, man.
-Is that right?
I thought it was Atlanta.
-No, no, I went to Atlanta --
I moved to Atlanta in like '92.
I was like 18, 19 years old.
There's -- you know,
White kids go to the beach
for spring break.
Black kids were
going to Atlanta.
-Oh.
-Don't know why.
There was no beach.
I don't know.
We just went to Atlanta
for a thing called Freaknik.
-Freaknik?
-Yeah, it's like a picnic for
freaks when you're young.
It was -- it was really cool.
But while everybody's there
having a good time,
everybody's like,
you know, partying.
You know what people
do on spring break.
They're -- you know,
they're doing that.
But I was seeing
Black people do well
for the first time in my life.
I was shocked at how well
they were doing.
So I went back to New Orleans
and loaded up my Hyundai
and moved to Atlanta.
That's where it all
started for me.
-That's wild.
I mean, now,
Tyler Perry Studios,
you have the largest studio
in the United States,
in the country.
-That's what they tell me, yeah,
that's what they tell me.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, they film everything
there, all these projects --
"Walking Dead,"
you did "Coming 2 America,"
"Red Notice," Marvel movies.
-Marvel movies going on there,
yeah.
-Do you know secrets?
Marvel secrets?
-I do not.
Listen to me,
just to make this clear --
[ Drum beast ]
Come on, man,
there's no drum roll here!
No, no, no, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
I don't -- I don't go to --
like -- okay.
When the stages are empty,
you know, something is going on,
I will go and make sure
everything
is all right at the stage.
So if you see people rehearsing
and shooting things,
it's like, "Oh, wow,
that's cool.
That's what's going
to be in the movie?"
And so you start
writing it down.
But no,
that's not what I'm doing.
That's all B.S.
No.
The only time I know
something is like
they'll call me up and they say
we're doing gunfire
or explosions or something like
that, they'll let me know.
-Because you own the -- yeah
-Yeah.
-So you can tell --
you would know
if Tobey Maguire
is in the new Spider-Man?
-I absolutely would, and I would
know all of those things,
because he would be there.
-Yeah, so you walk by,
he'll say, "Hey, Tyler,"
and you go, "Hey, Tobey."
-Yeah, I'm like, "I don't see
you. I don't see you."
-So you did -- you did see him?
-No, did not -- come on.
[ Drum beat ]
[ Laughter ]
That's good.
-Not bad, right?
-That's really good.
That's really good.
Good work, good work.
-I'm telling you, man,
I'm working on my acting.
I'm taking acting classes
on weekends.
-That works, but just that whole
jolly, thing, man, that was --
[ Laughter ]
-That was the worst.
-That was B.S.
-That was the worst move
I could ever do.
I know.
-Won't let it go.
-Will you never --
will you forget --
ever forget that I said "jolly?"
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
You have ruined my entire
Christmas because every time
I see Santa,
I'm gonna think "jolly."
We lost because of that.
[ Laughter ]
-I -- did you ever think that
you'd have this studio
and be open to so many different
projects and things
happening and that creative?
-It's a wonderful thing, no, no.
All I wanted to do was --
was just -- I built the stages
so that everybody else could
rent them and use them,
because i don't use the stages,
but I use the rest of the lot.
-Yeah.
-So it's really great to see
all of these other productions
coming and setting
up shop and doing all these
great things.
It's wonderful, man.
I love it.
-We just talked about you
on the show.
We do -- I should send you a
text every time we talk,
but you get like crazy.
But Whoopi Goldberg was here.
-Whoopi, I love Whoopi.
-Man, she was so funny,
she crushed,
and we were talking about
"Sister Act 3."
-Yeah, yeah.
-You made it happen.
-I don't know if I made it
happen as much
as she made it happen,
but I wanted to be a part of it
to make sure that we
could get it done,
so I signed on to it so that we
could get it done, but yeah.
She already laid the groundwork,
man.
So to have "Sister Act 3" --
we need a "Sister Act."
Don't we need "Sister Act?"
I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love it.
-Everything going on
in the country,
we need something good.
We need some of that kind of
humor from back in the day.
-Madea's back!
-Yes, yes, Madea's coming back.
[ Laughs ]
I'll tell you, I was done, man.
I was done, but so much was
going on in the country,
I said, "You know,
we just need to laugh."
And what do I -- what tool
do I have in my box
that can make people laugh?
And it's Madea,
so I dusted her off.
-Yeah.
-And here she comes.
-Bigger and better
than ever, man.
-When does it come out?
Do we know?
-We don't have a date just yet,
but it's definitely on Netflix
and we're excited, so everybody
gets the chance to see it.
-Yeah, and do you ever,
by the way, slip into Madea,
like, just talking?
-Like I just did
a few minutes ago?
-Yes, exactly, but I'm saying,
like, in situations
where you shouldn't?
Where you're just like...
I don't know --
you what happens?
If I get excited,
my voice goes up high
and people think I'm trying to
do Madea, but I'm just excited.
So I've been speaking
at funerals -- [ Laughs ]
-Oh, my, no, no, no, no, no.
-Yeah, and some of them
are on YouTube.
I'm speaking at funerals,
and you hear my pitch go up
out of the excitement,
and people think
I'm making fun and doing
Madea, but that's my voice.
She comes from me.
I own that broad!
[ Laughter ]
She comes from me.
You hear that?
That's exactly right.
-I own that broad.
-When we come back,
I want to talk about
your new movie...
"Don't Look Up."
-Yeah, "Don't Look Up."
-"Don't Look Up."
-"Don't Look Up." Tyler Perry.
More right after the break.
Stick around, everyone.